[Music]
as we move towards a future of
autonomous vehicles one problem that
automakers and car parts suppliers are
grappling with is what to do when the
car's computer needs the humans to take
control again and how to know what the
human is up to this is one answer to
that this is the z4 steering wheel from
auto live and if you can see here around
the edge it's got the series of LEDs
embedded into the wheel and as I move
the wheel around or move my hand around
the wheel you can see the blue lights
chasing me around that's done because
there's a whole series of little
infrared sensors all the way around the
car knows when my hands are on the wheel
when I'm gripping it I'm in control the
lights of blue but take my hands off the
wheel that on Thomas driving is
available in whatever vehicle this would
be installed into and this is just a
concept then those lights would go green
to show autonomous mode is available and
they can also go other colors orange red
warning I have a retention required to
try and get the driver's attention in a
much better way than just a little you
know which is pretty easy to miss quite
clever though having these means that
there's a fastened line of communication
between the car and the driver and you
can use them in other ways for example
if I was to get an incoming phone call
I'm just going to stand on the demo my
hands are on the wheel instead of blue
under this thumb over here I've got
little green and red LEDs ring to answer
the call there and then red defend it
and then we're back to blue and I'm in
control of driving again so this is just
one solution but it's an interesting way
of looking at how to start grappling
with the problem of communicating not
just what the cars doing to the driver
but what the drivers doing to the car
[Music]